jean-michel on va pas se mentir malgré
ta langue de bois
mine de rien jean michel tu cherche
l'amour oui mais pourquoi chercher le
grand amour partout alors que souvent le
grand amour sous vos yeux
il est sous tes yeux mais n'anime pas
moi à ma question il est sous tes yeux
s'il vous plaît on dit que l'amour
frappe parfois la porte et aujourd'hui
il ne fera pas n'importe laquelle
puisque l'amour est en ce moment même en
train de frapper à la porte du plateau à
jean-michel j'aimerais qu'on va voir
quelques images qui date un peu mais qui
aujourd'hui vont prendre enfin tout leur
sens rappel fatou peut encore appeler
fatou il ne te reste plus que quelques
minutes 47 minutes pour appeler à la fat
ou si tu veux que gilles
reviennent avec toi tu veux revenir avec
gilles tu connais le numéro gilles tu es
pressé par là ça commence mais j'ai cru
à la libération tout à l'heure mais là
le stress remonte des coups de fil pour
tous remonter le moral regarde les gens
qui s'est le plus c'est des plateaux
dire que c'est l'appât minérale est ce
que vous avez envie de vous et avec
caroline a tout de suite
franchement c'est vrai pour c'est que
c'est la femme de votre vie c'est la
femme idéale elle est sublime elle est
jolie intelligente elle adore le 6
[Applaudissements]
y'a aussi
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu jean
michel et il s'est encore vérifié reli
bonifié comme du bon vin bien bluffé les
débats s'achèveront
[Musique]
je
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et de tout ce qu'on s'est dit et oui car
au c'était bon c'était fort c'était pure
ses grands chevaux que tu es choqué je
n'ai pas de se poser quand même fou mais
j'avais cru comprendre qu'elle est et
rhin non non oui en vrai j'ai toujours
dit oui le premier jour ici à tpm fait
que je trouvais que j'emmenais était
très très beau et complètement mon style
dans l'absolu dans l'idéal moi c'est un
pierre arditi mélanger achètent pas il
déclare me fait un peu italien et les
îles et chic il est sympa à brett et le
style de tout le monde mette à personne
[Applaudissements]
les personnes devant vous c'est
incroyable ah ouais je vous le dis il ya
quelques jours un élément apparemment
est venu changer de cours de l'existence
taux de cette table
regardez vous nous dira après si c'est
du lard ou du khallouf
la chute était trop courir tout donné on
doit donner aux toilettes au 15 mars
quoi c'est fini tu as un nouveau ton mec
c'est fini
sa photo pour garder un petit d'homme
[Applaudissements]
ko avant nous dire bien sûr si c'est dur
la roue du khallouf
on va faire ce qu'on appelle le test de
compatibilité avait demandé à caroline
et jean michel bien vouloir me rejoindre
au centre de ce plateau et après bien
sûr caroline tu nous diras tout comme la
il vous dirait l'adjointe au maire de
levallois si ces fonds se marre se doit
j'ambitionne s'est fait descendre les
casques cross et le recruteur alors vous
voyez que ces manuels
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si vous allez mettre ces casques et vous
allez danser collé serré puisque ces
casques sont reliés directement à la
love machine très mignon qui va analyser
tous vos comportements attention s'agit
d'un test de compatibilité
ce n'est trouvée dans mon film préféré
des sous doués en vacances et me rassure
c'est vital prochainement dans les
salles caro a cédé sans demander
pourquoi toi et moi
dessiner
inutile fui ou deux nuitées
bref c'était notre destinée
tu ne pourra pas y échapper
c'est gravé dans la vie
oui
[Musique]
attention vous avez dansé connaissiez ou
d'avoir tout de suite les gars et je
vous le dis c'est extrêmement je dis
bien tomber criirem fiable l'avez vous
le dis si si si j'vous l'dit ou dit je
vais tester cet après midi et vous tiens
je les ai testés peux pas vous dire avec
qui on pouvait pas non plus tout savoir
chier ces coeurs sims peuvent avoir tout
de suite non non on va voir tout de
suite votre compatibilité alors regardez
maximale attention
jean-michel caroline s'il vous plaît on
peut savoir comment alors jean-michel
votre coeur est rempli donc vous êtes à
100% malheureusement carreaux afin de
les rendre à ses juges à nîmes en direct
-sans d'europe tout le monde a vu c'est
tout ça celle ci une nouvelle porte donc
à jean mi melle si on les aime surprise
mais premier travail là rowling est ce
que vous êtes en ce moment où toujours
pas ma toujours parle même pas ce soir
jean-michel apparemment c'est pas de la
saveur sans vous n'avez pas les la passe
et seule une dernière chance tout à
l'heure ah ouais merci faites vous quand
même un petit bisou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore